there's a lot of issues and fights over
water rights on Maui
um you know water they don't have a lot
of a lot of places get water if the
stream's not running it's not raining
there ain't water there there's not like
a bunch of you're surrounded by sea
water so
um but yes there was issues I don't know
the details so I don't want to say what
it was but there was some kind of issue
that caused uh caused them to have to
slow getting water out to to put the
fires up but the the wind was going at
100 miles an hour they were talking
about the actual fires were progressing
at like 60 miles an hour 70 knots crazy
I mean you're you're done like you're
not outrunning that obviously it's like
you you're there's nowhere you're going
to get inside to get away from me
because the buildings are all you know
it's like you are just people were
jumping in the water yeah you know it
looks like a thousand people are dead
and it looks like a lot of that thousand
are gonna be kids it's a horse kids that
got sent home from school because of the
fire and they didn't know where to go
and they burned alive